WATCH JOHNNY WAKE.
>> Rick: WAKE-UP CALL FOR N NLA.
THAT LINE WITH LUCIC AND
GAME AS AN AV
PLAYING ON HIS OFF WING.
FOR THIS AVALANCHE TEAM.
THEY HAVE ANOTHER UP AND COMING
YOUNG STAR HERE, ALEX NEWHOOK.
THERE HE IS. HE'LL PLAY IT
BACK BEHIND FOR HANIFIN AS THE
FLAMES AND THE DEFLECTS
OVER.
COGLIANO TAKES IT AWAY AND FEEDS
FIRES IT BACK AROUND FOR TANEV.
HE HAD A GOAL THE OTHER NIGHT
AGAINST THJARNKROK.
DUBE CHASING,
THIS PLAY AT THE BLUE LINE, AND
UP, FOUR SEPARATE PLAYERS
TOUCHING THE PUCK WHENGO.
KUEMPER IS ABLE TO HANG  Rick: N
ADVANTAGE CALGARY LOOKING TO
JARNKROK  JUST CONTINUES TO H, T
SHINE, DOESN'T HE, DILLON DUBE?
GETS THIS PASS AND UHE
PUCK WITH A GOOD PLAY.
KYLINGTON TRYING TO A SHOT OFF
THE
GUDBRANSON TRYING TO MAKE A PLAY
TO MANGIAPANE, PICKED OFF BY
NICHUSHIN.
HERE'SEE THEY
GO RIGHT TO THE FRONT OF THE
NET.
THERE'S B
TOEWS, HERE'S MAKAR.
HE SURVEYS.
RANTANEN, ly: SO GOOD.
MAKAR LOSES THE PUCK LOW INNAY
AFTERNOONS.
WE GO UPSTAIRS TO KELLY AND
RICK, GUYS
>> Rick: RIGHT COLORADO.
BURAKOVSKY THERE, ROUGH, PUCK H.
FLAMES BREAK OUT.
NICHUSHIN.
KURTIS MacDERMID SKATES OUT.YES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT MARKSTROM.
HE MAKES THE SAVE AND
RETREAT, THEY OUTMAN THE FLAMES